I got a challenge for you
given that you uh
have been an outspoken critic of Donald
Trump can you say one thing you like and
one thing you don't like about Donald
Trump and perhaps can you do the same
for our current President Joe Biden one
thing you like when you think you
dislike so it's harder for me to do the
one thing I dislike because there's so
many things I dislike but the one thing
I like uh about uh Donald Donald Trump
um
he believes that um
America
should be a better country he I disagree
on what he thinks it should be but he's
not someone he's not a declinist he's
someone who believes the world could be
made better I disagree with what he's
trying to do I disagree with how he's
trying to do it but I like the fact that
he thinks it can be better his whole
argument for himself is that he can make
things better I don't think he can but I
think things can be made better so I
like the second half of that sentence
when he says I can make things better
take the eye out I like the can be
better because there are too many people
on the left and the right who think that
the you know that we can't make things
better we have to accept them as they
are or they're getting worse uh I I
think a world without hope is horrible
and I think what he has offered his
followers is a kind of hope so
underneath his message is an a kind of
optimism for the future of this nation
yeah it's a narcissistic optimism but
it's still an optimism yes that that he
he's promising that if you elect him
again he will make things better
and I think people need to be told and
we need to believe that we can make
things better so that part I accept and
I reject those who say
we can't make things better my whole
historical career is about showing that
history gives us tools to make things
better
so I like the idea of trying to make
things better and giving people hope and
reason to believe that things can be
better what's the main thing you dislike
about Donald Trump I I think he has uh
no concern or care for the welfare of
anyone other than himself
so assuming I'm a basic human psychology
perspective
and I I think he doesn't even care about
his children I think he's just I think
it's it's him I think he's gone into a
rabbit Holly might not always have been
this way I did watch him a long time in
New York City when I was growing up in
New York and I think he's been in this
path and I think it's an extreme it's a
clinical kind of narcissism
so you know do you when you analyze
presidents and you've written about
presidents you don't just look at
policies and so on you look at the human
being of course you have to leadership
is about human policy matters it's one
part of the equation but it's not the
only part what about uh Joe Biden uh
what do you like and what do you dislike
about so what I like about Joe Biden is
in contrast to Trump I think Joe Biden
really right now in his career
sees his role as The Shepherd of
democracy he really believes that it's
his role as president to make our
democracy more stable
and more vibrant I think he really
believes I think that's why he's doing
what he's doing right now and he comes
from that system the political system
that basically the the process of
democracies he's worked there for many
decades it's all he's done yeah that's
all he knows that he and he wants that
to propagate For Better or For Worse and
he's not an extreme Democratic partisan
at all he's actually he's actually a
pretty middle-of-the-road guy on most
issues um some people don't like him for
that but I think he is about he is about
democracy
um what do I dislike about Biden I think
he does not have the capacity
right now to provide the language and
the public discussion of where our
country should go
he doesn't have a he doesn't have a
language to inspire and build
enthusiasm for the future
that'll probably be one of my I mean
because I'm a sucker for great speeches
and so for me that's definitely a thing
that stands out for several reasons one
in a time because we've been facing so
many challenges like the pandemic
it just seems like a like to me it seems
like an easy like layup
there's so many troubles we're going
through that just require a great
unifying president well the great like
just if I were to speak uh candidly
about kind of the the speaking ability
of Obama for example Obama would just
destroy this right now both on the war
in Ukraine on the pandemic all of it the
unified there's a hunger for unification
I believe maybe people disagree with
that because they've they've I think
people have become cynical in that the
divisions that we're experiencing are
kind of already really baked in they're
really they're really planted their feet
but I don't think so I think there's a
huge hunger maybe a little bit of a
quiet hunger for a unifier for a great
unifier I agree I agree and I think
what's what a great speech does is it's
like a great piece of music or poetry it
helps you see something in yourself and
feel something you didn't feel before it
doesn't overcome all different I don't
think that speeches are unifying but I
think what they are is they're
mobilizing and you can mobilize people
to the same mission with different
points of view
do you think Trump derangement syndrome
is a medical condition
um also is there such thing as uh Biden
derangement syndrome what I mean by that
I said it's a it's a funny kind of
question but why are people so deeply
outraged
seemingly Beyond Reason at their hatred
or support on Donald Trump but hatred in
particular I've seen a lot of friends
and people I respect
like lose their mind completely yeah
so I'm not sure it's a medical condition
or not because I'm not a medical doctor
so I you know my kids say I'm the wrong
guy in the doctor I'm I'm a doctor so
let me take you from here no uh P the
fact that you get the doctor signed
after getting a PhD is a ridiculous
hilarity to me hilarious ridiculous so
as as the wrong kind of doctor I'll say
I'm not going to comment on whether it's
a medical condition but I do think
you're on to something
um I think there is a way in which
um these men become
touchstones of anger and there's all
kinds of anger and anxiety that people
have
and I've seen this in other historical
periods you you Center it on one person
in a way that's John Wilkes Booth in
Lincoln
he actually didn't have a personal beef
with Lincoln
it was that all the things he feared
were were manifest uh in that and I
think that's an old story and then it's
made worse by social media
and the way we're bombarded and it's
it's like
it becomes a drug I mean they're people
I know who hate Trump or Biden so much
and just watch them it's not that they
don't watch them it's that they do watch
them right and it's just sort of and it
triggers you and and you get hateful and
then you feel like you've done something
by shouting out your hate or typing in
and and so I don't know if it's a
derangement syndrome I think it's a it's
a way in which our energy gets channeled
and expressed in totally useless ways